>> BOYD: All right. Hi, everyone. My name
is Ryan Boyd. I'm a developer advocate at
Google. I'm working on Google Apps and the
Apps Marketplace. How many of you attended
the last session? Okay. The last session that
I did just a few minutes ago. So, there may
be a slight bit of overlap at the beginning
here, but then we're going to be diving into--in
application. So, we're going to give an overview
of Google Apps and the Apps Marketplace. And
then we're going to dive into this application
that I built called SaaSy Voice. SaaSy Voice
is an online voicemail application for a small
business. And we're going to be talking about
how you build, integrate, test and sell that
application on the Google Apps Marketplace.
So, first of all, and this is kind of the
repetitive material, bear with me, but Google
Apps is about messaging and collaboration.
It's about tools like Gmail, Calendar, Docs,
et cetera that allow organizations to efficiently
message and collaborate with each other with
minimal IT cost. We have 30 million active
users on Google Apps with three million businesses.
There are more than 3,000 new businesses signing
up everyday and these businesses are of all
different types and sizes. We have the small
mom-and-pop shops, small retail stores, et
cetera, all the way up through major enterprises
and educational institutions. These organizations
don't just want the messaging and collaboration
tools that we offer them in the cloud. They
want other different types of applications
in the cloud. They want things like a CRM
or a project management application and they
want that to be accessible wherever they are,
whether it'd be from their mobile device or
from the web browser. And in order to do that,
we've launched the Apps Marketplace. We launched
the Apps Marketplace back in March and basically,
it's a place for you guys to build applications
and launch them to customers of Google Apps
where they can discover, purchase and install
these applications which are well integrated
with their data that they store in Google
Apps. So, this is what the Apps Marketplace
looks like. It's at google.com/appsmarketplace.
Since we're--we're in an environment that
most of you probably speak Portuguese as your
first language; I will say the Apps Marketplace
right now is English only. But we do have
applications which are written in foreign
languages. And on the Marketplace, there's
a number of Japanese apps as an example. And
we definitely plan on internationalizing at
some point, so. The Apps Marketplace has over
200 cloud applications on it and it's definitely
growing. We show some logos here, these are--these
are people who initially launched with us
back in March. There were 50 applications
which launched with us, so we've grown significantly
since then. And there are applications of
all different types. There's expense-reporting
applications, there's image editors, there's
mailing and marketing applications, all sorts
of types of apps. So, the steps to sell your
application to Google Apps customers: One,
you build your application. You can build
your application using any tools and the hosting
providers you want. You won't believe the
number of phone calls I've been on where a
potential partner says, "But our App isn't
written on an App Engine." I don't care. You
can have your application on Easy2 and launch
it on the Apps Marketplace. Of course, we'd
love App Engine to be a great environment
for you to build your application on, but
we understand you may be invested in other
technologies. Second, you integrate your application.
After you build it, you want to integrate
it with Google Apps. The first and only required
method of integration right now is adding
Single Sign-On via OpenID. And we'll see what
that experience is here shortly. And you can
also go to my next talk, in this same room,
where I talk a little bit more about OpenID
and OAuth in the different used cases. The
second thing that you want to integrate with
is some of the over dozen different data integration
points. You don't want to have users have
data silos. They want to reuse their Google
Calendar data. They want to reuse their contacts
and all within your applications. So it makes
it a lot easier for them if you integrate
with these APIs. And then, there are some
gadgets that we'll talk about as well. And
after you build and integrate your application,
you can sell your application, go wherever
Google Apps goes. And there is a one time
fee of $100 to create your listing and then
there is a 25--or 20% revenue share when our
Billing APIs are available in a country where
you are located. So right now, there's a revenue
share exemption. You can bill your customers
however you want using your own, like, credit
card merchant provider or what have you and
you can do that directly. So, you can launch
paid applications in the Marketplace and then
eventually, when our Billing APIs are available,
and I'll show a demo of that later, you'll
be--you'll be required to integrate with them
and that's when the register will take place.
So, SaaSy Voice. Like I said, SaaSy Voice
is an online voicemail application for small
and medium-sized businesses. It's not an application
which I've launched and tried to make money
on, but it is a functional application which
we've written. And here's what the app looks
like. So, I'm logged in here, I'm seeing--here's
my phone number and my extension, here is
one of the voicemails that I've received.
The target customer of SaaSy Voice is something
like Smart Law Firm. Smart Law Firm is a fictitious
small law firm that has, you know, a number
of different employees, but they don't have
an IT staff. They don't want to have to maintain
an IT staff and they want to have all our
services in the cloud. So, we're going to
be using both SaaSy Voice and Smart Law Firm
in these examples. So first, I want to talk
about the features of SaaSy Voice before it
was integrated with Google Apps. So, it has
an online sign-up. As a small business, you
could go to SaaSy Voice and you could create
a new account. Once your business create an
account by providing an email address and
a password, you paid for the application with
the credit card and then you would assign
all the different extensions within your company.
You would input the names and extension numbers
for each person within the company, so that
they could receive voicemail. Every user within
the company would then receive an email that
looks something like this; you're all very
familiar with it. It basically says, "Hey,
your administrator has created an account
for you, click on this link and set a password."
The user would then set a password and then
they'd be able see their voicemail. Fairly
simple but, you know, much more difficult
than it actually needs to be. So, we're going
to talk about how we make that easier for
both the users and the administrators by integrating
SaaSy Voice with Google Apps. So, there are
many different types of integration points.
But like I said, the first and required integration
point for the Apps Marketplace is OpenID.
OpenID is used to create a single sign-on
experience. This single sign-on experience
all starts from the universal navigation menu
that's at the top of Google Apps. You may
notice in Google Apps, at the top of Gmail
and Calendar, you have this navigation menu
that say's, you know, Mail, Calendar, Document,
Sites, and then there's a More menu. We want
your users to be able to access all their
cloud applications from one place. So when
they click on SaaSy Voice in this menu, they're
immediately signed into the application. There's
no need for the user to grant authorization
to pass their identity to the app, as you
typically see with OpenID because the domain
administrator has already granted that on
their behalf. In addition to the users having
one central place to access their applications
in this menu, the administrators also have
one central place to access all their cloud
applications from the Google Apps Control
Panel and configure them, enable data access
and that sort of thing. So, there are many
different integration points that you can
use for a Marketplace Application. This is
some of them, the, you know, most popular
sort of integration points are things like
Calendar and Contacts. But Document List is
becoming increasingly popular as well amongst
the Apps Marketplace applications. So, let
me show you what the SaaSy Voice application
looks like to install and start using by a
single sign-on. So, here is what we call the
listing page in the Apps Marketplace for SaaSy
Voice. At the bottom here, you have Recent
Customer Views. Unfortunately, I've not published
this listing yet. I don't have any great reviews.
But if I did, I'm sure I'd get a lot of customers.
And then at the top right is our Call to Action.
We want administrators to add the application,
so when they hit that--the Add button, it
asks them to input their domain name. So,
I've inputted smart-lawfirm.com here. Hopefully,
that makes it a little easier to see. And
then I can hit Go. And--okay, Internet is
working. That's great. I had some little--little
problems before. All right. So, I've logged-in
to the application and then I go through this
install process. This install process is a
very simple install process that's similar
for all applications in the Marketplace. The
first thing it asks me to do is agree to the
Terms of Service. I have a very simple Terms
of Service for this sample application, it
says, "You agree that you will love this application."
I'm sure my lawyer would not be very happy
with that Terms of Service, but it will work
for today. I agree, I continue and then we
see a list of data access that the application
has requested. So when an application is created,
it creates a manifest file. We'll show that
here during the presentation. And that manifest
file describes lists of resources that that
application needs access to. In this case,
the application needs access to the list of
users on my domain. It needs access to my
Google Docs and my Google Contacts. And when
I say "my" I mean my company. So it's basically
access to those resources for the entire company.
And so, I'm really comfortable with this application,
I built it myself. If you do not build the
application yourself, you want to do a little
due diligence and make sure you trust the
application vendor, but then you grant data
access. And then the next step is an optional
step during the install flow where you can
configure the application. So I'm going to
hit Configure Application here. And this is
going to actually jump over to the SaaSy Voice
website and go through a new customer forum.
It needs–-it already knows my email address,
but it needs a little bit more information.
Because this application is currently doing
billing in the application itself, it's not
using Google for billing, it also asks for
my credit card number. So I'm going to say
my company name here as Smart Law Firm, a
little auto-complete action helps. And I have
my credit card number that is a fake test
account, please don't write it down and try
to use it, it won't work. And then I am prompted
to set-up voicemail for my company. Here you
see the first integration. So, it knows who
I am but not only does it know who I am, it
knows who the other people are in the company.
If you were to set-up this application, SaaSy
Voice, and you didn't have Google Apps, or
the application wasn't integrated with Google
Apps, you would literally have to type in
the username, first name and last name for
every single user in the company. Well, it
makes it--this application, by integrating
with Google Apps in the Apps Marketplace,
makes it a lot easier. It just lists out each
of the users in the app and I can scroll down
and hit the set-up voicemail button. And it
says, "Congrats. You've set-up your voicemail.
Please click the button below to continue
the installation." I hit that. Now, I have
a choice right now. I can enable the app now
or enable it later. By enabling it, every
user within the organization gets the navigation
menu for a SaaSy Voice. So I'll show you what
that looks like. The application is now enabled,
this is where I would go in the control panel,
in the future, to configure settings for it
but for now, I'm going to click the inbox
and I'm going to show you my More Menu here
and we can see SaaSy Voice is listed here.
When I click SaaSy Voice, I'm immediately
logged into the application and I have access
to my voicemail. So it's as if the application
was part of the Google Apps suite, it has
a lot of the same capabilities. I don't have
the microphone hooked up, but this is a voicemail
from a guy named Litigious Larry. Larry likes
to sue a lot of hospitals and he was calling
to check up on the status of his most recent
case. But when Litigious Larry called me,
typically for most voicemail systems, you
might have caller ID. You might know their
phone number and you might know their name,
but this actually looks up in Google Contacts
and gets a lot more information. And we're
going to be talking about that in the next--as
part of the presentation here. So let me jump
back to the presentation and show you how
we did the Single Sign-On. First of all, Single
Sign-On and OpenID has a lot of terminology
associated with it. You can see some of the
terms there, we'll be talking a little bit
more detail about that in the next talk, but
it sounds really complicated. It's not hard
in practice because a lot of people have done
the hard work for you. They've created libraries
that do all of this. Now, Google Apps OpenID
has a slight different discovery process than
regular OpenID, but there's also libraries
to handle that for you. In today's examples,
we're going to actually be using PHP; not
necessarily everyone's favorite language,
but a language a lot of people understand.
So here's some code about how I'm doing the
Single Sign-On via OpenID. In order to do
the Single Sign-On via OpenID, I first need
an OpenID consumer object and it goes through
here and creates that consumer object. You'll
notice the first line uses memcacheD in order
to create a store. This is basically the OpenID
relying party in speaking of this terminology,
but you can copy and paste this code, it will
work. But the OpenID relying party, which
is the SaaSy Voice application, actually needs
to store associations with the server. So
those are stored there, you don't need to
know all the details, but copy and paste this,
it will work. And then you make the request.
So, when making the request, you can see at
the top it says--we got the OpenID consumer
from the last method that we just demonstrated,
and then we go begin. And we're passing the
domain name. The way Google Apps OpenID works
is you need to know the domain name of your
user to log them in. From that universal navigation
menu, when you clicked on SaaSy Voice there,
Google actually automatically passes the domain
name to the application for that application
to use it for this process. But if you're
having a user log-on from your own website,
you have to ask them for their email address
or their domain name. Then the middle part
here builds up, what's called an Attribute
Exchange Request. Attribute exchange is an
extension to OpenID and it provides things
like the email address of the user and the
first name or last name, language and some
other things for the application. And then
basically, you're forming up the request,
you're sending it over to Google and once
you get back a response, you need to parse
that response. So here's a little code for
doing that using the PHP OpenID library. Basically,
it's getting out the user information, the
email address, the first name, and then it's
looking up in the database for that user.
And that's like the typical process in the
database; you would store the OpenID for a
user and you'd get a--fetch the record for
that user based off the OpenID and then create
a native session within your application.
So you saw some of the data access and you
saw how we created that universal navigation
link. This is the application manifest which
is user--used to configure those items. And
you can see at the top here, you have a link
set-up. That is the URL that my application
went to during the very beginning of installing
the application that allowed me to configure
the extensions for my users. Then there's
the navigation link and an OpenID realm. So,
like I mentioned before, OpenID provides certain
information about the user. It's generally
declaimed ID. This is a URL that represents
or a URI that represents the user. You can
store that in your database and that's what
you use to match when you're logging in--a
user in. But there's also that additional
information that you can get. You want to
be sure that you're talking just with the
Google Apps OpenID providers if you're going
to trust the email address, the first name
and the last name. If you're definitely talking
to the Google Apps OpenID provider, then the
email address is what's provided by the domain
administrator and the first name and last
name are the same. So when we fetched users
on the domain--so we saw the list of all the
different users that we could assign voicemail
boxes to. We did that based off of OAuth access
to the data on the domain. It's called two-legged
OAuth in this case, but basically what happens
here--as a developer, you configure this manifest
and you say your application needs access
to this information for this reason and that's
what gets displayed in the installation process.
So in order to fetch users on the domain,
you know, previously you saw with OpenID,
we created an OpenID client. In this case,
we're going to create an OAuth client which
is basically an object. We use Zen framework
for the PHP Google Data API's library. And
so I use the Zen OAuth classes and like the
Zen HTTP client here. But basically what it
does is configure a consumer key and a consumer
seeker which Google gives you as a developer
when you register your application. And then
it builds up an object, an HTTP client, that
whenever you send requests using that client,
it automatically adds the appropriate OAuth
signatures. So, the OAuth is a part [INDISTINCT]
what we're really here to talk about, we're
here to talk about is provisioning API and
how you get the users on the domain. As you
can see, it's a fairly simple process. Basically,
you pass that OAuth client, you create a few
objects, you retrieve a feed from Google that
is authorized by OAuth and that has a list
of all the users in the domain. You can then
build up an array of those list of users and
pass that over to whatever is rendering your
webpage if that's how you're using them. So
I want to go back to the demo here and show
the next little bit of functionality. Actually,
I already started talking about some of this.
In particular, how the contacts API's are
used. So when I receive a phone call at--or
receive a voicemail, this system actually
looks up in the user's Google Contacts who
this voice mail is from. In this case, it
knows a number of different phone numbers
for Litigious Larry. So if he calls from any
of them, the system can look it up and it
knows that it's from Litigious Larry. And
then we have all sorts of other information.
We have other phone numbers we can call him
back on. We have an email address we can use
to return his email, all because we integrated
with the users Google Contacts. Now, I haven't
mentioned this thus far, but this application
uses what's called Twilio. It's an API for
voice applications and I definitely encourage
you all to check it out. It's a really great
API. It's very easy to use. Anyway, so now
I've looked up the information about the user,
made it a lot easier for the employees of
my company to know who they're receiving voicemails
from and contact them back. I also have a
call log. So the administrator is--within
this application can get a call log, a log
of all the different voicemails that were
left in the organization. Very handy for auditing
purposes, but not so handy if you just have
a list of them, you know, in a web browser.
It's much more handy to have a link like this
that says "Export to Google Docs." I'm going
to click on that and you could see a new tab
was opened. And in a second here we will have
a Google Doc representing that call log. And
the Google Doc is as a spreadsheet. Now, why
might this be powerful? It's powerful because
users are familiar with certain tools. A lot
of business users are familiar with spreadsheets
and they're familiar with analyzing data in
spreadsheets. So what are we going to do here
is build a quick formula here to see how many
voicemails my users are getting. So I'm going
to say, "Give me unique values of column C."
And then I'm going to count. Oops, sorry.
I'm going to count for each of these unique
values or unique users, how many voicemails
they've received. I'm going to drag this down
here, call these "Voicemails" and then insert
a chart. So now, we're going to show you how
you would do that. How you would fetch the
user's Google Contacts and how you would export
the docs. It's very similar on the authorization
side to what we saw earlier, so we don't repeat
that. But in this case, you're adding one
additional parameter here, the xoauth_requestor_id.
The xoauth_requestor_id represents the user
on behalf of whom you're making requests.
So if you're make--if you have a user John
logged-in, the xoauth_requestor_id should
be John because the request that you're making
are going to act with the privileges of Don--of
John. And what it's going to do is say, "I
want to retrieve John's contacts feed." So
we're building up a URL which is just the
kind of generic query URL, we're not passing
any parameters. But we're building up a generic
contacts URL and say, "Retrieve the feed of
John's contacts." And then we loop through
the contacts and add them to an array. And
after we have the contacts in an array with
all the phone numbers and all, it's fairly
easy to look it up and figure out who this
user is and--oh, sorry, who the caller is.
For exporting a spreadsheet, there are a couple
of different ways to do this, but the easiest
way to export a spreadsheet is to create a
CSV file. That's what Write Call Log does
and you're all probably familiar with creating
CSV files. It's very simple. So Write Call
Log creates a CSV file then forms up a URL.
Again, having that xoauth_requestor_id, identifying
the email address of the currently logged-in
user and uploads that file. It's a one simple
line to upload that file. You're passing the
MIME type as a CSV, so Google Docs knows to
create it as a spreadsheet. And then you're
getting the URL back from Google Docs and
that's what was displayed in the web browser.
So the web browser opened up that new URL
with the Google spreadsheet, fairly simple.
So we had about a hundred lines of code. I
did count them, but it was quite manual because
I counted them from the slides, but hopefully
that hundred number is right. In a hundred
lines of code, we added Single Sign-On via
OpenID. We had a very quick set-up process
using OpenID attribute exchange and the provisioning
API. And we integrated the user's data with
the contacts API and Google Docs. So let me
show you one other feature that I built in
this application.
And you may have actually seen this earlier
when I was logged-in, but I actually have
a gadget as part of this application. So that
when I'm actually checking my email on a regular
basis--I unfortunately spend the majority
of my day in email, I'm sure a lot of you
do as well--I want to see all my different
voicemails. I don't want to just come--have
it in as an email, but I wanted to know what
my task list--what voicemails I have to listen
to. I want to be able to easily call one of
my contacts from the Contacts API, and I can
do that all with this gadget. Now, gadgets
like this aren't actually installable as part
of Marketplace applications, but they can
access the same OpenID services and you can
provide as a developer some instructions to
the user on how to install the gadget. It's
a fairly simple process, but in the future
we plan on having more installable services.
So the future, you're probably wondering,
you know, the Marketplace has been around
for a little bit now. What's happening? The
number one thing our engineering team has
been working on are the Billing APIs. The
idea behind the Billing APIs, as an addition
for our domain administrators to have one
central place to manage their data access
for the cloud applications, for users to have
one place that they can log in to all their
applications and have all those integrated
experience. You also want to have administrators
to be able to manage the payment for all the
applications in one place. Now I'm talking
about this slightly prematurely. We're planning
on launching it for U.S. vendors soon. International
availability will be sometime next year. We're
going to be rolling out on a country by country
basis. Believe it or not Billing is very difficult
for legal and tax reasons and all that stuff.
And like I said before, until we have the
Billing API available for your country, you
can feel free still to launch applications
in the Marketplace, collect money from customers
using your existing payment collecting methods
and those will be revenue share exempt. Let
me give you a demo though of what the Billing
APIs will look like once they're available.
And this is a YouTube video, so hopefully
this will play well. All right, so you could
see it's the same sort of start of the installation
process. I'm logging in to Sassy Voice here.
Sassy Voice is displaying a couple of different
billing plans. I'm going to choose the $8
per user per month plan for a toll-free number.
I'm going to say I have three users in my
organization that need voicemail. And then
I get an invoice. And at the bottom here,
because my credit card is already stored because
I've added other applications, I can just
agree and pay. My order's going to be processed
using that credit card. And I must've been
recording this on a very slow connection or--all
right. And then I can enable the application
right as soon as I've agreed to the billing.
Then Google will handle the monthly recurring
building--billing for the application. And
then I can actually select individual users
to give voicemail and those users are the
ones that will receive those navigation elements.
In the universal navigation, those are the
ones that have gained access to the application
and those are the users I'm paying for. So
basically, it streamlines that flow a lot
more. Now, so I've gone through the whole
process. I've talked to you about how you
build an application, how you integrate with
OpenID, how you integrate with various sets
of data, all to launch your application and
make it available for the three million businesses
that are using Google Apps to go out and purchase.
Now, here's some resources. There's a lot
here, but if there's any ones that you want
to scramble down quickly, you're welcome to.
And I'll send my Twitter profile at the end
there if you want to contact me. But I definitely
encourage you all to check it--check this
out. If you have any great application ideas
for business to business web applications,
the Apps Marketplace is a great way to distribute
them. Right now, there's another talk going
on, on the Chrome Web Store. It uses a lot
of the same technologies if you're trying
to distribute applications to consumer. So
you can reuse a lot of the knowledge that
you've gained via OpenID, et cetera, if you
want to write an application and distribute
it both to businesses and consumers. So I'm
available up here for any questions. I'm going
to give another session starting here shortly
going in through OpenID and OAuth, but until
then feel free to come up and ask me questions,
then I'll be available, obviously, at the
end of the day as well. Thank you very much.